all right let's look at a couple other
things that I have for you today I'm
going to play a clip for you now from
what is supposedly the straight news I
don't mean heterosexual by the way I
think when I'm talking about Fox News
it's important to clarify Fox News does
this thing where they say okay listen
we have our straight news and we have
our opinion
sure the opinion side has a right-wing
lean because those are the individuals
we have they are allowed to give their
views and say whatever they want but
when we do news when we do Straight news
our anchors they are just doing news now
we all know that that's not true we know
we've been known for years that that's
not true one of the techniques that the
fox straight news shows will do to do
the very same opinion that the opinion
shows do is Tucker Carlson or Sean
Hannity at night will give some
disgusting opinion about something and
then the next day Fox News hard news
shows report on the opinion
as if it is newsworthy right so Tucker
will go oh immigrants make our country
dirty and poor
but that's opinion the next day the
anchor who doesn't do opinion goes a Fox
News
host Tucker Carlson says that immigrants
make our country dirtier and poorer is
this true or not now we debate that with
one talking head versus another talk
okay so you know that technique but
Harris Faulkner is a particular Fox News
straight news anchor who is increasingly
straight up using Tucker Carlson and
other Fox News hosts disgusting rhetoric
about immigrants to the point that she's
openly using Nazi type rhetoric now on
her
uh program I guess we call it Okay let's
listen to what she had to say yesterday
kioneer Senator thank you for being in
Focus today yeah
thank you Harris so The Fallout over the
bombshell report on the DHS asking for
military volunteers to do chores
for people who've shown up at our border
including picking up the garbage after
them now I've shown you on this very
program an exclusive video that they
leave a trail of unspeakables from The
River's Edge until they can enter
someplace illegally
where there are no border patrol nobody
there to stop them some sensors that
that are very very slow to respond to
because there's so many of them
they make our country look like what
they left and now our people are going
to be picking up all that trash and all
that excrement
it's in Focus oh boy what a hard-hitting
story
um this is essentially straight up
Nazi style rhetoric that Nazis used
about Jews which now many of these right
Wingers are using about hispanic
immigrants from a central in South
America it's it that they have been
building up to this on Fox news for a
long time okay this is essentially using
Tucker Carlson's poorer and dirtier
rhetoric about immigrants they make our
country look like the
crappy place they left behind the trash
that they left behind and now we're
going to be going around picking up
their trash and excrement this is
straight up textbook what the type of
stuff that used to be said about Jews oh
they bring disease and they bring filth
and they infect and they get released
into the wild sort of like animalistic
type dehumanizing language and
understand that what I showed you is
supposedly ostensibly not opinion
journalism that's that's the news hour
on Fox News
um it's just overt at this point in time
and so when we wonder you know how can
these what we call primary Fox News
viewers people who primarily get their
news from Fox News how do they believe
so much stuff that's not true how do
they believe lies about climate change
the election
vaccines taxes the economy oil electric
vehicles how how is it that they believe
just so much stuff that's not true it's
because they only watch Fox News or
almost only watch Fox News they can't
tell the difference between news and
opinion and what is a fact and what is
an opinion
and Fox News deliberately makes it
difficult and by difficult I mean you
know like
an intelligent person would be able to
tell the difference but Fox doesn't help
distinguish between its opinion and news
shows and this is the type of stuff you
get absolutely disgusting